good afternoon everyone my name is
Jackson with me is my colleague any so
in this afternoon we're going to talk
about how we designed a real-time next
basic action recommendation system i
salesforce so before I go into the
actual details of of the system let me
give you some context and the context
we'll start with data so as we all know
and aware that we are we're going
through this very amazing digital
transformation where you have all these
mobile devices your laptop computers
sensors smart home home appliances
that's deployed in the world they're
connected
they're sending data to different places
and and business these days is facing
the challenges how do we adapt to this
right some of the business is already
starting with this journey like hotel
chains like Marriott they start to have
these mobile devices where you can
check-in log and lock you your your room
you can send a text to concierge they
will start to send in your whatever
request you're asking for so and they
have like 110 million I think
rewards rewards profiles and they can
start to serving them in that fashion
so with these unprecedented devices they
have very high processing power storage
they're connected and and the
possibilities start to seem unlimited
and these possibilities starts to get
multiplied by all these emerging
technologies such as artificial
intelligence these days and professor
and doing have the thing that artificial
intelligence is is the new electricity
well what's powering and giving these
artificial intelligence is actually data
the researchers the science researchers
and practitioners has already start to
aware of that data is actually key to
unlock a lot of machine learning and
artificial intelligence tasks this is a
research I think it's pretty well known
figure that is published almost twenty
years ago that is studying different
performances of NLP models with
different different data size as you can
see pretty clear here that the data the
size of data have a huge impact on the
accuracy of different models even the
worst-performing model trained with a
billion records will outperform the
best-performing model trying to say like
10 10 million records so this also
explains why companies like Facebook and
Google where they have these massive
data sets they're leading the research
in a deep learning space so data really
matters in this case a lot so you may
you may aware of Salesforce as part of
the good old CRM system where the helps
salespeople to keep track of their
customers their prospects and to enable
selling activities however over the past
few years it really has grown to the
complete customer success platform with
not just sales for marketing commerce
platform services community so this also
enables us to get a lot of data as well
where you actually see a complete angle
of how business and and and how they
engage with the different customers ok
so for example this is just in one part
of the service force which is marketing
cloud we see a lot of user match queries
there are capturing events on behalf of
our large our clients it also sends out
about three billion emails every single
day and it keeps track solves all the
twits Facebook updates emails SMS push
you name it so with this data that
really just enables a lot of different
applications that's powered by machine
learning itself just to give you a few
example here is that like email
frequency and some time optimization
really is to find the ideal the ideal
frequencies and time to send emails so
that as business itself they can have
higher engagement but as a consumer
these emails or promotions are not that
annoying okay so to really get through
the topic of today's talk is really
about personalization how do you how as
a business to engage with their
customers so so in the in a good old
days or still in the small communities
these days
business owners themselves will know
their customers individually like you
know their life they probably interact
with them and they sell them personally
so that it can start to give more
personalized recommendations or
promotions or incentives whatever so so
these will feel much better for for for
driving sales and it becomes more
effective however as we start to govern
things at large scale a large businesses
with online activities you don't
actually see people face-to-face there's
no way to actually doing a two-way
communication it becomes very hard so it
the challenge is really in this case so
in order to model and help driving on
this two-way conversation we can really
just separate two kinds of different
events where the first type of events is
called activity where they are customer
initiated events like I maybe there's a
website going to a banks branch I can
call the customer service so these are
customer initiated at the same time the
business may
initiating events like we call them
actions where at some time they can send
you emails and they can when you visit
the website they can give you
recommendations they can send you
promotions or different pop-ups to say
hey maybe you want to try that so these
are two two different basic activities
or we call it events that we can model
sometimes there are overlaps we call you
know interaction sometimes they don't
but these are really just the basic
building blocks of how such a system can
be built with this in mind then at
whenever there's an overlap between an
action and activity you have a touch
point or our interaction in our case so
based on customers you have like we are
well different we all prefer interacting
with businesses or even individually
very different ways some prefer like
this short and sweet things I just I
just wanted to get this done today I
know exactly what I want just give me
that and some will maybe just want to
know a bit more they're less confidence
or or they may prefer to know do a lot
of research before they making a
decision
so these journeys will be very different
and you want to engage customers with
very different ways so they they will
all go through the same phases awareness
consideration purchase service and
eventually some make it become loyal
customers but how they actually go
through this journey could be completely
different so you need a system to be
able to drive I send them different type
of messages so this is what we call the
the next fashion action system so as
such there's a tool called interaction
studio which basically just help people
do exactly that so how do you they allow
this reporting tools you can see how
customers engage with all your potential
touch points you can check there's
different side of
like reporting tools to see where they
drop off where they start things like
that and what marketers do these days is
they start to analyze on other users
maybe segment them into different kinds
of group by different criteria and then
they have a set of actions they could
utilize the actions could be ads it
could be emails
it could be recommendations it could be
certain incentives and then they start
to see and think about how you can
combine them at different stages to send
to the users but they don't know how to
do that based on different profiles so
they have to try different options and
well they can design some maybe testing
scenario to to see which are more
effective which are not and in the end
they may learn something that applies to
a certain set of customers and deploy
whatever strategies they have learned so
on the paper this seems like a fine
approach right you based on data you
learn behaviors and then you deploy
whatever is working based on what will
you see as a result however there are
three key difficulties the three key
challenges in this case the first of all
is think about the action space you may
have tens of them but in terms of how
you're sequencing them you combine them
that you goes to the combinatorial space
which is ginormous even you start to
understand and are able to eliminate
some of them you will need someone who
really understand how statistics works
to be able to design all these a/b
testing scenarios like to be able to
actually generate the insights that
tells you inference so even after that
say you export or everything you deploy
your perfectly design a be testing
scenario it takes a lot of time in order
to to have the results so in the end you
may have a perfectly working solution
but we learned is what was working for
the past month after that time
things may already changed due to
seasonality and maybe your business
objective also shifted towards another
goal so these are the things is like we
can't we can't it's very hard it's a big
challenge however if you think about
this right these these times are really
maintained there's a fixed approach to
this and the ghost is pretty
well-established
you have certain things you want to
maximize and you have a set of
possibilities that you want to explore
and and there and and you just need to
try these different combinations
these are maintained for human analysts
however these are really like that's
what machine do best is to see this
point husks identifying patterns and
I'll start generally like certain rules
so in this case the problem really is to
find some certain policies Republic PI
which is a rule to say given a user and
their current context or stage they're
at and the return action in the end it
will maximize the general rewards you
can define it says revenue or whatever
based on your business okay so you have
that so one typical approach emotional
earning practitioner I will do is well I
can I have historical data I know how
they perform based on different actions
we may have designed in the past based
on certain business rules or certain
strategies you've chosen before and we
just train a classification model at the
and return that however this won't work
in practice the first of all is you will
not be able to get the feedback for for
the actions for new actions right you
may have a new set of things you may
want to push and these feedback
solutions are available and also it will
be biased towards
the analyst has been designed in the
past so what the model learned basically
is try to mimic the past behavior rather
than improve and explore the space the
action space so that won't work
however we could do much better than
that so if we carefully examine what
people are actually doing today
by analyzing behavior explore action
space try deploy and apply in simple
terms given a context explore learn
exploit and go through the cycles again
and again try to try to reply and
improve overall so this does sound like
a very actually well-defined and studied
problem called context remote error and
bandit for those of you who's not that
familiar with contextual multi-armed
bandit the problem setting goes this you
have a fixed set of resources you may
not know how much reward you will return
and the problem is given certain rewards
you know the rewards like the problem is
how do we define I utilize a strategy so
that overall we can balance between the
learning and the exploitation so this is
a classical reinforcement learning
problem explain explain defy the the
rewards versus sorry the exploit
exploration versus exploitation scenario
so you pay a price to test out different
things but at the same time you may lose
you may have the risk of of of deploying
whatever things that may have a much
higher reward so a simple strategy could
be I can simply just shift in between
times so for day one or the first hour
I'll try to throw out actions randomly
and test out and collect data and then
the next hour we use whatever we learned
from the previous hour to
to use to return the best action that
have seen learned in a previous hour
that's a fine strategy or you can split
the users to write you have a set of
users that you clearly just don't care
about that's the control group and use
whatever you learned from that subgroup
to drive more revenue from the rest of
the group okay so so that's that's a
fine starting point we can start with
but clearly we can do a lot better
so the basic scenario the based on
intuition is that for for the things you
do not about you probably want to give
it more chance to show where the actual
rewards are or the probability or
eternal rewards are for the things you
already know you're pretty certain if
they have higher reward you can start to
give that option more chance so here
becomes a balanced one typical approach
is called upper upper confidence pound
and the scenario is well I can I can
before I know anything I can probably
can calculate what is the optimal time
so given if I don't have a lot of data
all of them will have a high probability
higher confidence bound so I can start
to send data to send the actions with a
much higher confidence bound and then
with over time when you start collecting
data the the confidence bound will
shrink the IFRIC confidence band will
shrink as well so that you can start to
balancing between the date the
directions with more data and actions
with less data but higher bounce okay so
the one this is a deterministic approach
you can also use the publicity approach
which is called Thompson sampling where
you start to model different actions
with their probabilities probability
distributions so you have a prior
distribution starting will probably be a
uniform distribution and then you start
when you collect data you start to
seeing the peak and you sample from
those two distributions
basically sampling technique will help
you balance between which actions you
can choose in real time okay so that is
what you can do right now when existing
techniques however clearly they did not
really work given the actual scenarios
we're dealing with now Annie was you're
going to talk about a few challenges
where actually start applying them and
play with with real data so on a high
level the system receives activity and
context from the environment and then
they use it to generate the next best
action to take and then return it back
to the environment and after the
reactions to the recommended actions
observed their feed back into the system
to update the policies so the policies
can be updated after each iteration or
periodically depending on the need and
computational cost so overall this is an
interactive system that learns
automatically from the environment has
been used and then from a user point of
view a policy is basically a machine
learned mapping from the future space to
the action space it can distribute users
across different actions that can
maximize the overall reward so initially
this standard context remote embedded
motherhood's
pretty well for us however as our
problem becomes more complicated very
quickly we found it hard to attack the
title few challenges one key challenge
is that when when we have multiple
objectives that we want to optimize for
it is very hard to design the single
reward strategy that can work for all so
for example we want to optimize for
single ticket purchase
also seasonal TV purchase and we may
also want to increase the user
engagement and perhaps move users
forward in their stage progression as
much as possible and then it becomes
very tricky to mix all these different
objectives together and it might be
relatively easier if we can obtain a
relative ways that can measure the
importance of different objectives for
example if we know the dollar value
associated with each objective that tied
to the revenue it may work to combine
them together according to the weights
however if we don't have that importance
waiting then it becomes very tricky to
combine them together and then it
becomes more even more problem when the
different objectives are not even in the
same category so in this case like
ticket purchase and the stage
progression and not even in the same
category so that it's it's very awkward
and not intuitive at all to make them in
any ways and another challenge is when
faced with multiple objectives it is
quite hard to minimize the
counterfactual regret so assume that we
can get the importance of waiting for
different objectives and we know that
goal B is more important so that we
rewarded higher and then it is very
likely that more users will be
recommended actions towards reaching
group B but in reality they this may not
be the case because for some users they
may have a much higher chance of
reaching goal C although it is rewarded
lower and for some users it may have
very little chance of reaching go P
although it is really higher so in this
case we may end up with much larger
regret due to this kind of lack of
personalized recommendation
so in order to handle these challenges
with designed and built hybrid contacts
to moti unbanded model to handle
different objectives and further build a
propensity score on top of it
the purposes propensity score serves as
a policy selector and it hits the
personalized item policy for each
specific user according to their
different unique characteristics and
this hybrid moti on bandit model
consists of multiple policies and each
policy is optimized for one or more
objectives depending on the
characteristics so this hierarchy
structure provides us with more
flexibility when our problem space
becomes better and it can easily be
extended to handle more complicated use
cases so in our use case we trained
standard multi-class classification
model that takes users entire histories
input and it's struct put the users
profile Vanity's there are behavioral
patterns and intent and then use it to
predict which grow or Road category has
a highest chance of achievement by a
specific user at a moment moment and
then the user is fit into the
corresponding policy to generate the
next best action to take
so this with this propensity score we're
able to find the best path for each user
according to their interests their
behavioral patterns at the moment and
instead of always picking the the
highest rewarding policy and then this
mode hybrid multi-armed bandit model
allows us to handle different objectives
more accurately and properly so there
are many types of modern bandit model
algorithms we use linear models for some
policies and non linear models for
others and all the policies utilized
thomson sampling to balance between
inspiration and exploitation so since
the data we have a time sensitive series
of events we can't really shuffle our
data set and do cross validation as we
already do in standard classification or
regression models so instead we designed
this rolling valuation method to better
simulate what would happen in reality so
in order to do that we start from the
beginning of our data set and a trainer
model always an adjustable window of
data and then use it to predict the next
a time window and then we'll roll
forward and repeat this process and roll
forward forward again until we reach the
end of the time series and then we get
these patches of predictions we compare
the predicted action and the actions
taken in reality and if they agree with
each other will hold a hit and then
that's the overlap area and for all the
hits we calculate the weighted average
predicted score and the observe the
rewards and then that gives us a
measurement of how close our model
represents the real-world observations
and further we also try to let the
overall expected reward and overall it's
observed the reward and then comparing
those gives us a sense of how much
counterfactual in one can expect so now
we know how the system is trained and
evaluated their fuel dimensions can be
configured and they experimented in the
system so first of all the training
window size determines the Model Model
quality and in the shoulder window well
that's more reactive to your changes and
it that's more quickly and then longer
training window will recommend more
stable and robust recommendations and on
the other dimension one can choose to
exploit the best performing action to
maximize immediately or to explore other
possible actions to gather more
information for now so in order to
implement this so this couple of things
that needs to be aware of as well so in
in in a typical scenario you wake expect
whenever you perform this prediction
each interaction you would be able to
learn about solving the feedback as well
however in practice is not possible you
send out the recommendation and you will
actually learn from after the fact
whether they took the action or not
that's that's very typical so so when
you import this you want the
recommendation to be separate from the
training service this also have another
benefit as well because typically when
you need to apply this kind of system in
the world customers are not that
confident it will perform so they tend
to be a bit more cautious and there will
be other set of customers that's
actually not using your recommendation
recommender as well and there's no need
to throw that data away it's actually is
still very valuable so that's the other
part and also there are things that's
just not online there are places you can
you can send these pings these trackers
and send to the system but there's
there's certain aspects of fall flying
like you visit a dealership and they
record whatever things afterwards I'm
gonna upload the data afterwards so
these reports of batch capabilities so
that's that's one reason why we actually
do need these to be different things and
also in terms of so many real-time you
can't perform these feature based
calculations every single
they need to be updated about a
synchronously so as well so you would
need a features store for all your for
all the known users that needs to be
updated but by a different system but
used with all my system took to do the
recommendation I just found some
highlighting in terms of technology so
we've been using for the training we've
we've been as a group using spark a lot
in our cases so there's no brainer to
use sparked we also have a pretty good
streaming capability it's pretty good
batching capability and the color region
is not that different anyway so that
it's that and features store you want
very fast updates and you want you want
the reads to be fast as well so a
database like Cassandra work pretty well
in our case so we're using everything in
AWS so that's that's the dynamo DB which
is almost the same
in fact cassandra is inspired by the
dynamodb paper initially I think and the
service is just standard web service it
could be implemented by anything we're
using play because we're using Scala in
general I hope there's something useful
that you learned today and thank you
very much
[Applause]